good afternoon the cdc issuing another
eviction moratorium this
one is set to expire october 3rd now
that's if
legal challenges don't end it sooner
thanks for joining us here at five
o'clock i'm denise valdez and i'm
kirsten joyce
the moratorium applies to areas with
high rates of spread of coven 19.
clark county falls right into that
category this may buy some time for
tenants facing eviction but as the
itunes vanessa murphy has learned
it may not protect them completely
vanessa joins us now to explain vanessa
landlords can still move ahead with
evictions the cdc moratorium may prevent
them from that final step though of
kicking tenants out of their homes so
tenants can't totally rely on this
moratorium to protect
them barbara buckley who heads the legal
aid center of southern nevada points out
a decision was recently made
in a las vegas justice court stating the
moratorium
doesn't apply to nevada residents she
says she disagrees with the decision and
she believes it'll be overturned
but it's an example of why tenants need
to take action to protect themselves
we're a little worried that people hear
the word moratorium
and they think they don't have to do
anything the cdc
moratorium stops the service
of a final eviction order for 60 days
but it's not a final solution
for the rental problem a spokeswoman for
governor steve siselek says the state is
expecting more guidance from the cdc
in the coming days buckley offers these
five steps for tenants
if they receive an eviction notice one
respond immediately meaning
file an answer with the court within
seven business days two
apply for rental assistance three seek
help
four fill out a cdc declaration five
apply for and attend mediation
if tenants have applied for rental
assistance here in nevada by law they
cannot be evicted while they're waiting
for the application to be
processed there is a wait but the money
from coronavirus relief funding
is there now we've heard from frustrated
landlords who say they need rent money
and many tenants aren't applying for the
rental assistance
buckley says landlords can apply for
financial help through a state program
called home means nevada we have links
for both tenants and landlords
at eightnewsnow.com